ce n'est plus en ligne il est de nouveau
en ligne
nous sommes de nouveau en ligne vous
mais bon évidemment de la perdu du temps
vous les avez perdu beaucoup de temps à
cause de ça et donc n'ont pas pu nous
concentrer sur la partie mais là du coup
on a perdu beaucoup trop de temps à quel
dommage ça le faire revenir en jeu quoi
c'est dommage c'est dommage de match
aller on revient autour on revient à les
g4 boom dégazage 4 ou bon ben ok mais
qu'est ce que tu fais toi même et pour
qui tu te prends mais qui tu es toi pour
rejouer comme ça tu sois intelligent tu
croit plus malin que les autres vient
faire un bras de fer qui glisse qui fait
lui qui sait ce qui va y mange le pion
beaucoup plus con que toi fais très
attention à monsieur x 4 1 dégage non il
joue pas mal là pour le moment quand
même on joue à fond dans l'esprit il
faut le reconnaître mais là c'est sûr
qu'elle prend des trois du coup j'ai
dame prend et tu vas rester avec une
double attaque
tonton fait quand même attention à ce
que tu vas faire au prochain tour
cavalière 3 bon je prends ok mais je
vais prendre ici je vais prendre ici et
je vais te coller dame prend g7 je vais
te je vais même pas de prendre en baie
de tanger de faire tomber un beaucoup
plus intéressant fait quand même très
attention à ce que tu joue un jeu très
dangereux la miss tartaglia
ouais bon bah je vais prendre ça et je
vais prendre ça je met ma tour ici et je
vais pousser mon pions
mais je veux venir de ce côté là ok ça
j'ai pas aimé fou g4 mais bon ok on fait
ce qu'on peut
mais on va tout est changé ok c'est pas
si simple que ça comme position à c'est
beaucoup plus simple maintenant à les y
pousse dégage
ces crues très intelligent vous en savez
on sert à quoi au final
l'avenir est dans ton coin agréable
bon il essayer d'être plus malin que
nous mais il n'a pas réussi entre les
gagnants plus dans l'esprit des cabanons
pas besoin faux moi je te dis faut
manger beaucoup moins dans l'esprit et
dessins mais devient vient manger le
pion match et qui est beaucoup moins
dans l'esprit que moi je suis beaucoup
plus dans l'esprit que ce joueur vous me
le craquage
c'est génial c'est génial il en peut
plus il n'en peut plus il a en pls
cosmique de niveau 50
et là je crois comprendre en pleine
implosion
là je pense qu'il est en train
d'imploser
le truc quand ils font ça c'est qu'il
faut jouer très très très normalement
laure manaudou l'air de rien comme ici
on joue est normal enfin dès qu'on ait
mis au matos fantastique c'est
fantastique on entre à lui faire péter
un câble thiam attendent maintenant
annonce au nom je donne la dame
oh quelle horreur ok alors heures c'est
moi qui ai pété un plomb aux noms
commencent à abuser travailler plus dans
l'esprit que moi dans cette partie on va
abandonner
or quelle idiotie
aïe aïe aïe bon allez on va repartir
mais bon il n'a été plus con que nous il
nous a maîtrisé je sais pas comment j'ai
fait j'ai raté sahara assez dur là là on
est en pls là c'est nous qui sommes en
pls aussi celles à contre-pied la soirée
on va essayer de se battre à fond
il nous a contredit en pls
bien voir qu'on se bat à fond parce que
là ça ne va plus ça ne va plus les
parties sont bien débile il faut qu'on
s'accroche il faut qu'on s'accroche
partie donc plus aucun sens c'est génial
c'est pas mal fait et ça les f4 enfin
qu'on s'accroche à fond là je voulais
partir avec la dame c'est pénible je
voulais revenir sur la cinquième en
danger on est très mal on va encore la
perdre il ya peut-être retourner le
match avec avec cette partie a nous a
retourné le cerveau a les boules qu'on
donne du matos faut qu'on donne des
pièces on est quand même très mal on est
très très mal on est excessivement mal
on est complètement foutu on est
complètement foutu on ne peut plus rien
faire mais bon madame ans la dame ici
roi des huns allez on se bat et les
tontons sur un malentendu
oui pas de paix rhdp tient à rien c'est
de la merde total mais un il a peut-être
plus peur de l'esprit quoi du coup ans
qu'il a gagné une partie a pris la
confiance quoi il a pris la confiance et
il a pris la confiance là c'est pas bon
il va falloir le faire redescendre sur
terre
il a trop pris la confiance il va
falloir le ramener sur terre
et moi j pour le ramener sur terre
on va jouer des échecs très
conventionnelle c'est super
conventionnelle à ce qu'on va faire
tu vas voir on pousser les pions au
centre à fond
là c'est pas très conventionnel tout ce
qu'on fait est bon là on a planté à
l'aise quand même envie de mettre madame
beckham ac devenu tellement du hourra
échec c'est devenu tellement de la merde
c'est génial c'est ce qu'on espère
depuis des années un que ça arrive comme
ça tout le temps aller là est ce que est
ce que aia le fou qui reste en prise et
du coup ça n'a pas trop fonctionné notre
histoire là là là qu'une finale de
[ __ ] couleurs opposées faire ça à 6 h
pas si grave l'aller le pion loin
à
doublé colonnes dc5 c'est une faute il a
tour des cinq maintenant certains fous
ces trois échecs on va revenir on va
gagner un peu de temps j'ai super mal
joué
à
non non non non non haye avait pâti
avait pris le fou quelle horreur bah il
a beaucoup mieux joué que nous je sais
pas ce qui nous arrive très mauvaise
série là tout d'un coup très très
mauvaise série
bon allez va falloir qu'on se
reconcentre ça ne va pas ça ne va pas on
a perdu la partie qui ne fallait pas
perdre
hélas depuis la concentration n'est plus
là la concentration nous suit allez les
mecs faucon faut qu'on se refasse la
cerise et bien il prend une fois la
mettre le pion g3 mais je sais pas
annoncer mauvais ça ne va plus ça ne va
plus ça ne va plus on va faire bouger de
quand même
non ça ne va plus bon ce qu'on va
réussir à faire quelque chose et quelque
chose les tactiques ne passe plus il n'y
a plus on a on a perdu le mojo on a
perdu le mojo enfin le retrouver parce
que là il est plus là plus prendre f6
aller ça encore une fois sa semi passe
passe même pas du tout on a vraiment la
tête sous l'eau là il ya tellement
important la confiance dans ce jeu là il
s'est mis à bien joué 1 depuis alors
qu'ils jouaient très mal dans un premier
temps
un peu de mal à y ait cette finale il
nous laisse un peu envie malheureusement
été trop gagnant au départ en fait
malheureusement été trop gagnant au
départ aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
bon c'est très problématique ce très
problématique c'est très problématique
tout ça part d'une partie complètement
ridicule perdu avec une dame de plus et
maintenant eh ben on n'arrive plus à
jouer ont jugé que des mauvaises
positions maintenant je sais pas j'ai
perdu quelque chose ait perdu l'esprit
voilà un très bon début mais un très bon
début nous n'attaquons plus le roi nous
nous nous ne sommes plus dedans nous ne
sommes plus de droits puissants seront
des petits trucs stratégique des bilans
je sais pas les parties sont tenues
stratégiques ceds est devenu
complètement de la merde la forme et
qu'on se reprenne
alors qu'on pousse comme des idiots vert
vers le roi laisse à nous faire du bien
ça lâche 4g et 5g car être allé mais
voilà ça ça c'est notre jeu ça hop ça
c'est notre jeu de pousser comme des
comme des idiots médaille à calais prend
h4 et où à chaque fois il ya un truc qui
comme si tout ce qui marche en notre
faveur au début et en notre défaveur
maintenant j'ai plus d'idées j'ai plus
d'idées j'ai plus d'idées bons plans en
faire peut-être le fou à l'époque on va
prendre ça allait il faut la gagner
c'est la faulx aussi c'est un peu de
chance allez un peu de conviction bien
du matos allez on est on est quand même
bien la halle et boum
allez ça part de là ça part de là on a
fait h 5 h 4 est ok ça s'est bien passé
à l'ebu on y retourne il faut arrêter là
on a fait n'importe non je voulais faire
à le missclick mais du coup on donne
deux pions ouais mais du coup on n'est
pas du tout dans l'esprit la non non non
non non on va attaquer le pion c'est
cette année ça c'est bien ça sagem sa
dame prend des 5 voilà ça y est on
retrouve l'esprit enfin enfin on refait
des choses qui ressemble à quelque chose
lui qui avait prononcé cet échec ne sais
pas si c'est bon enfin les tactiques
reviennent à faire car il y eu deux
d'ailleurs
ouais ça c'est pénible un peu ralenti le
rythme mais aucun veut faire ces trois
pour l'enfermer à l'air pour l'instant
on va l'enfermer passé par là bas peut
pas s'approcher du cavale du conte va se
barrer de l'autre côté dire pour le
moment ça va
il ya peut-être fou prend 1,5
on va revenir pas max d'idées pour le
moment mais bon c'est pas mal d'idées
mais bon
j'ai beaucoup de mal
allez allez allez allez
non mais c'est horrible ouais c'est
horrible mais ce h4 là ça nous a coûté
cher
bon allez allez allez revenons revenons
renault on va lui faire le e6 v5
ok c'est pas mal ça fait à peu près move
est un peu on va les chasser
ok c'est pas grave les cavaliers f6 ça
va ça ça tient bien ça tient bien alors
il sert à faire un espèce de rock
artificielle à les boums
allez faut qu'on continue dans cet
esprit-là sacrifice de daham boom qui
avait france et trois as tu dégages boom
qui est france et 3 quand même
boum chute des rocs et hop on revient
avec le foot tranquille tranquille à
venir hcr non tu ne viendra pas bon mais
c'est pas mal quand on commence à
sacrifier tous là je commence à
reprendre la confiance quand on balance
des dames quand on se fait plaise
là je me dis ça va on place les pièces
on est bien on va pas les fous pranger 4
à main c'est à tout reproche
7 quel idiot quel idiot pourquoi je
laisse des trucs comme ça
enfin moi je suis dit que je voulais
faire de base mais j'aime pas du tout
en espérant que ça tienne de justesse
il me paraît change un peu de matos
il y avait cavaliers g3 non non non
pourquoi j'ai joué le pion là-bas au kef
le tueur en ces cas c'est vraiment le
truc a pas faire ou qui on a réussi à
gagner autant bon ben en partant de là
un truc sur life 6
c'est d'aller on va sacrifier faisons
nous plaisir
j'espère que ça matin ce serait bien là
de d'avoir quelque chose
comment ça défend pour lui
c'est pas croyable que sam ath pas quoi
c'est pas croyable
à
il faut réussir à le maté quand même va
falloir réussir à le finir
quelque 24 pendant sa fille nie pas le
job
ça fait pas du tout le taf la quelle
horreur
on a plus de temps et ok on va réussir à
gagner la dame mais on est très mal
autant
à
ah ah
ah ah ah
oh lalala lalala à
quelle horreur à boutons on était bien
on ne réussit pas le finir is débrouille
bien d'aller refaire un g5 poison il se
défend pas mal il se défend pas mal
ils ne connaissent pas le marabouté a
failli c'est vraiment il ya une partie
qui a qui l'a sauvée du maraboutage et
depuis on réussit plus du tout il a il a
trop pris la confiance l'a pourtant foot
bords des longs mais on est des pièces
de partout c'est n'importe quoi mais
qu'il en confiance il se défend à chaque
fois pourtant c'est pas faute d'essayer
d'en mettre deux partout hein c'est pas
faute de mettre des pièces emprise de
partout et d'essayer de le faire craquer
mais il craque pas et c'est pourtant pas
faute d'essayer les tontons c'est
vraiment pas faute d'essayer mais trouve
des tactiques de partout encore dame
prend il à cavalier la veillée
et il me fait réfléchir en plus le
bougre
c'est pas mal ce qu'il fait c'est pas
mal allez on va les taper à deux on va
taper ces deux allez on va le finir
quand même fini moi
allez hop un petit matin avec du
cavalier à 2 et cette fois-ci suracheté
je ne fais pas le mouse l'ip boom
enfin enfin on n'a pas fait de mal si on
comprend comment jouer il comprend
comment jouer au vrai échec
il sent les vrais échecs vous voyez il a
le mojo des vrais échecs on sent qu'il
est plus fort que les autres
c'est vraiment un bon joueur dans cette
partie on voit vraiment son son calibre
quoi un joueur de haut niveau
c'est un joueur de haut niveau qui à
fond dans l'esprit mais c'est vrai que
par il abandonne
aïe aïe aïe aïe après un petit a il fait
le il a tous les coups du tennis
il a tous les coups du tennis que c'est
bien joué
le roi à leroy roi et de roy g3 très
très bien tenté non sens on sent qu'il
est dans l'esprit à fond mais elle
al'avantage il est mieux tout de suite à
la sortie de l'ouverture il est bien sûr
le mec comprend les vrais échecs souffre
alors il faut il faut il faut s'incliner
devant devant devant ces échecs qui sont
quand même qu'ils sont quand même
sublime enfin géré par l'afld depuis
combien d'années on ne compte pas sur
des gens qui réussissent à faire à faire
de tels exploits je suis bien sorti de
l'ouverture il ajouté bonne couverture
il ay la dame prend des huit c'est
complètement gagnera sorties l'ouverture
ouais mais bon ils jouent les vrais
échecs
que voulez vous c'est complètement au
dessus conceptuellement
c'est complètement reçu conceptuellement
peut pas se battre contre de tels
concepts quoi on est on est forcément en
dessous on ne peut pas lutter on va donc
ya pas fou décade avec lui en prend
tours 8 heureusement si on réussit quand
même à gagner cette partie mais ce sera
un exploit
hall voltige on va pousser les pions on
va conduire un pouce et auquel cas elle
fout donner un échec
on va prendre et faire b2 et on va
réussir à damer quel exploit de haute
voltige rock et boum
là on sent quand même que ça l'a mis en
difficulté on sent quand même que trop
de groupes salah quand même
il joue dans l'esprit à fond après un
mais on sent quand même que ça l'aaf on
sent on sent que ça l'a marqué
physiquement quand même on sent qu'il
est très très marquée là donc sans qu'il
n'en peut plus c'est c'était trop pour
lui l'implosion du mec quoi il a juste
pété un câble quoi je crois qu'il n'en
peut plus je crois que je crois qu'on a
un nouveau champion on a un nouvel oscar
iott le mec non peu plus a fait
complètement explosé et je vous avais
dit c'est difficile physiquement de
tenir ce genre de truc c'est juste ça
fait beaucoup de parties complètement
débile à jouer c'est dur quoi même pour
moi
il va refaire cavaliers trois là il va
rejouer normal malheureusement mais en
fait ouais il faut pas oublier que c'est
plus dur de jouer comme ça que de jouer
normalement cas là le mec il a implosé
c'est fini c'est fini et on l'a fait
l'idée joue complètement la série à
force de se prendre des vrais échecs
dans la gueule bas ils n'étaient pas
prêts ils n'étaient pas prêts une telle
dose de vrais échecs en fait je pense
que la trop de vrais échecs c'est voilà
enfin je n'étais pas prête et pas prêt à
ça sur lui mais qu'il s'est levé ce
matin il a par ok quoi il a par ok je
pense que
lorsque le grand spécialiste des vrais
échecs francs que ce serait complètement
d'accord qu'on s'en débarrasse
on a un peu dans la merde
prendre le pion
c'est nous qui sommes malin
il faut qu'on a cherché b2 si on peut
malheureusement on a plus de temps ça a
pris trop de temps à défendre
j'aurais dû faire pousser 6 et adam
prend 17 c'est fini
il s'est ressaisi bon allez on en fait
une dernière il sera temps de nous
quitter mais bon il s'est ressaisi on
l'a fait on l'a fait quand même un peu
craqué 1
on l'a fait quand même un peu craqué
donc objectif objectif mission mission
réussie j'ai envie de dire on a rempli
notre objectif
pls donc vous pouvez être fiers vous
pouvez être fiers de vous l'objectif a
été rempli
l'objectif pls a été rempli à 200% ne
pourra pas dire je n'ai pas été en pls
fin à sa fin je refuse je refuse qu'ils
disent je n'ai pas été en place il a été
en paix à la silla et en pls ils le
reconnaissent ou pas il a été en pls
malgré le fait qu'on ait donné la dame
ce qu'il a un peu sauvé de la pls mais
il est quand même tombé en perez à un
moment donné il a été en pls je suis
désolé vous vous dit vous dites que vous
voulez moi je vous dis là étant ps bon
je prendre là j'aurais pu j'aurais
peut-être dû prendre là bas d'abord je
sais pas
on va lui donner une calloc'h on va
finir dans l'esprit à fond on va venir
comme ça
mince
à
allez hop un petit échec on va prendre
la whey mais bon
les cavaliers c6
à
ok on est tombé on finit là dessus on
finit sur cette partie moi c'était sympa
on a quand même gagné 11,9 même si ouais
voilà eu des hauts des bas
il ya eu des beaux débats mais j'espère
que vous avez bien aimé cette petite
séance de vrais échecs que ça vous a
fait kiffer voilà je pouvais dire ce que
vous en pensez sur le chat vite fait
avant de partir donc ouais j'espère vous
êtes amusé et j'ai réussi c'est en
retourné pour la chaîne et c'est pas
facile quand vous l'avez vu ça demande
beaucoup plus de concentration et sa
demande de faire n'importe quoi tout le
temps et donc c'est plus loin d'être
évident
j'avoue ce qui était pas content quoi
arrête avec ça non mais voilà c'est pour
un peu rigoler de temps en temps enfin
non pas toujours faire des choses
sérieuses allaient title tune et tout
mais c'est le moment un peu des tentes
ont fait nawak et du cou du coup c'est
cool plus haut c'est marrant on voit
jamais quand on voit les adversaires qui
font encore plus nawak que nous ça me
fait bien marrer donc on sera de retour
jeudi prochain
mais voilà je sais pas combien on est
aimé vous dirai ça et il faut toujours
revenir sur le discorde si vous voulez
discuter
allez les mecs merci à tous pour ce bleu
pour vous ciao soyez dans l'esprit jouer
des grob